the grand Bazar in Tehran is one of the
most important social and business hubs
in Iran built centuries ago is served as
a Lifeline for many Iranians throughout
its turbulent history it has seen
several disruptions by War civil unrest
and Strikes
with the rise of e-commerce the
traditional Grand Bazaar also quickly
adopted the new business style but
nowadays shopkeepers here are struggling
as Internet disruptions push online
business to the brink of God Labs
Muhammad Raza nadav has two shops in the
bazaar three years ago he moved half of
his business online
we had a production line in our Factory
that was dedicated for e-commerce but
the Crackdown on the internet stopped
our business before that we had 30
orders per day now barely one or two our
Revenue has dropped by almost 90 percent
if this continues I'll have to go for a
layoff and some of my employees will
lose their jobs
the Iranian government has been severely
restricting internet access since the
death of 22 years old Masa amini in
police custody nearly a month ago
support widespread protest
According to some statistics 11 million
Iranians have online businesses of
Varian scales about 9 million of them
rely on Instagram Iranians are now
turned into virtual private networks or
VPN to bypass the internet disruptions
the demand for VPN Services has
increased significantly since the
protest began but the use of vpns in
tightly restricted countries comes with
its own challenges it's not difficult
for the governments to block the IP
addresses of the VPN servers as they can
be found easily and that's why in Iran
these open vpns are only available for a
short time before they are identified
and blocked by the government
Iranian officials say the internet
restriction is necessary because foreign
governments are encouraging the protest
and the country is facing an online War
provoked by its enemies outside but
inside it seems like a punishment
my clients say their pages are not
accessible Instagram and WhatsApp are
completely blocked all the sales are now
halted people who rely on e-commerce
have lost all their revenue and cannot
even pay their bills in this digital age
we're all connected when I lose Revenue
I can't buy products from others and
they cannot sell this internet blockade
has destroyed the market
it's not clear if the Iranian government
plans to continue the ban on social
platforms once the protests end however
with soaring prices inflation at 45
percent and an economy crippled by the
years of sanctions the collapse of
online businesses here will likely make
things worse Jesus Sardar Al Jazeera
Tehran